would you tell us some of the
rituals which primitive societies had to
break that dependency on the symbolic
mother
all the big transitions in life
uh in all
uh societies have been accompanied by
so-called what ganep calls rit the
passage
rights of transition to make a ritual to
help
people to to to make the the step over
the threshold
now the most famous one which has been
studied mostly by ethnologists is the
ritual of initiation where the young men
are initiated into the
secrets of the tribal law and into the
secrets of
sexuality and
they have they have to leave mother in
their home
they are secluded in the bush they are
symbolically devoured by maternal
monster
they are reborn they have to generally
stand a lot of tortures
they are sometimes also homosexually
assaulted by the older men
with the idea of injecting the
masculinity and then they are generally
at the same time instructed
with the secret law of the tribe and the
religious traditions
and if somebody and a young man has
undergone all this
ritual of transition then he's
afterwards a full member of the tribe
he's a man
and many tribes call the ones who are
afraid or for some other reason not
initiated they say
he's not initiated he's an animal
meaning he has remained completely
unconscious he has remained in an
unconscious animal conditions
he's not really made the step to being
human